اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان اطلاقا المخطط العام لمطار الملك
سلمان الدولي وسيسهم المطار الجديد في دعم
خطه المملكه لتكون مدينه الرياض ضمن اكبر
10 اقتصادات مدن في العالم وسيكون مطار
الملك سلمان واحدا من اكبر المطارات في
العالم سيمتد على مساحه تقارب 57 كيلو
مترا مربعا وسيشمل سته مدارس طيران
بالاضافه الى 12 كم مربعا من المرافق
وسيعمل المطار على رفع الطاقه الاستيعابيه
لتصل الى 120 مليون مسافر بحلول عام 2030
ومن المتوقع ان يسيم المشروع بحواليس 27
مليار ريال ثانويه في الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي غير النفطي ضمن رؤيه المملكه
ينضم الينا هاتفيه وزير النقل السعودي
مهندس صالح الجاسر مع الوزير مرحبا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه من الرياضه اولا كيف
تقراون الاهميه لهذا المطار اليوم بهكذا
حجم بهكذا رؤيه وبها كذا ارقام ايضا
كبيره
لقطاعات النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه
والطيران
في المملكه
بفضل الدعم الاستثنائي التي تحصل عليه
يحصل عليها هذا القطاع من سمو سيدي ولي
العهد
وهو خطوه متقدمه في تحويل المملكه الى
مركز اللوجست عالمي وايضا يمثل خطوه مهمه
في
خطاب مدينه الرياض لتصبح احد اكبر 10
اقتصادات همم في العالم
معالي الوزير ايضا كيف سيسهم هذا المطار
في دعم خطط السعوديه بقياده ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان في انيربطا هذا
المطار بين الشرق والغرب بان يجي على
السعوديه مركزا لوجستيا عالميا مهما
كان هو
بتوفير الب
نيه با
ن لالي تطور صناعه الطيران
بالمملكه همم مطار ضخم جدا يعني بطاقه تصل
الى 120 مليون مسافر في عام
و ينطلق بعدها لاستهداف الوصول الى 185
مليون مسافر همم
ثلاثه ونصف مليون طن من البضائع بحلول عام
2050 همم يمكن المملكه ان تتقدم جوهريا في
هذه الصناعات العامه ويربط مدينه الرياض
في بقيه دول العالم همم شكل ثالث
معين لانجاز هذا المشروع والانتهاء منه او
حتى مراحل هذا المشروع
طبعا كمان ذكر في البيان الصادر عن صندوق
الاستثمارات العامه الذي يعني يقوم بتنفيذ
هذا المشروع ان ااه تبلغ الطاقه
الاستيعابيه همم
التشغيليه
لاكثر من 120 مليون راكب في 2030
وحوالي همم 185 مليون راكب في 2050 هذا
مشروع اتمخم جدا
يعني يتطلب عده سنوات في همم
ما احد المشاريع ضخمه ايضا مع الوزير هي
الاستراتيجيه التي اعلن عنها الامير محمد
بن سلمان في ما يخص
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل للخدمات
اللوجستيه اليوم هذا المطار كيف سيساهم في
رفض هذه الاستراتيجيه ما الذي سيضيفه
اليها ايضا
الاستراتيجيه
ممكن اساسي للاستراتيجيه السياحه
ممكن اساسي لخطه مدينه الرياض للنمو
والاستدامه ممكن لكافه القطاعات ال- همم
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه وجوده الحياه في
مدينه الرياض والمملكه
اشكرك جزيل الشكر هاتفيه ان التحق بينا
وزير النقل السعودي المهندس صالح الجاسر
شكرا جزيلا لك